jamais le délabrement de l'île
d'anticosti n'apportera ma signature
les contradictions de ce gouvernement
les sautes d'humeur du premier ministre
c'est carrément irresponsable
comment premier ministre peut-il refuser
de défendre des sièges sociaux et de
l'autre côté de faire fuir les
investisseurs
tous sont des défenseurs des milieux
naturels du québec dans cette chambre
y'a que moi il ya quel parti libéral du
québec on va continuer à le faire
l'histoire le retiendra alors plusieurs
sujets aujourd'hui mais on va revenir
d'abord sur l'île d'anticosti qui a été
encore une fois vous voyez au coeur des
échanges à québec
faut-il ou non aller de l'avant avec
l'exploration pétrolière tasha daniel
michel bonsoir à vous trois ans soit
michel j'ai commencé avec vous parce que
je crois qu on comprend tout ce que le
premier ministre couillard on veut
enterrer le contrat anticosti
mais pourquoi pas le faire tout de suite
pourquoi est ce qu'il attend puis
évidemment ça ne devient plus sujet aux
critiques qui puisent aux dix bals au
départ je pense que monsieur monsieur
couillard et sincère est un grand
amateur de pêche
il veut pas qui est de sa cage de de
l'île d'anticosti mais je pense que son
intérêt politique
je joue beaucoup là-dedans écouter le
client sait parfaitement ce qui fait les
déclarations à répétition contre
l'exploitation il est clair que ça ça
risque de provoquer des poursuites
judiciaires
il y en a tellement que c'est même à se
demander c'est pas que ceux qui le
souhaitent de manière à pouvoir vraiment
se draper envers l'on l'attendait dans
la partie du reportage qu'on a vu ça
ferait un excellent thème électoral ce
qui est le seul à défendre les milieux
naturels au québec c'est nous et je
pense que monsieur couillard est
exactement dans cette ligue la tâche à
sql
le québec y est un partenaire dans ce
projet anti que c est ce qu il peut
renier sa signature mais il peut
toujours le faire mais ça va coûter de
l'argent et coûtent 115 millions de
dollars
le québec est actionnaire à 35% de ce
projet on sait que si on brise les
contrats pétroliers avec les autres
compagnies vont dire écoutez dédommager
nous c'est ce sens un prix à payer
est ce que monsieur couillard porte qui
va gagner plus de prix politique versus
l'argent public qui va être dépensé
peut-être nous fait ce calcul mais c'est
un peu étrange de voir un hugo à
l'assemblée nationale
honnêtement un gars qui a beaucoup qui a
fait vraiment l'éloge du québec quand il
était à paris on dit d'ailleurs que
cette conversion de monsieur couillard
ce soit c'est vrai mais que ça vient
peut-être en partie de cette rencontre à
la cap 21 et monsieur couillard à ces
deux rencontres à jouer un rôle très
important pour premier soir et c'est
l'egypte à sa façon que genres et styles
très important d'être qui voulait
démontrer que le québec se joue un rôle
intéressant sur la scène internationale
sans être indépendant me la joue un rôle
important à gora eu sur les flux ans il
n'y a pas de doute là-dessus et monsieur
couillard s'en va début mars 3 mars à
vancouver la conférence des premiers
ministres son environnement
il veut un nouvel en position de force
évidemment donc tout ça fait de lui une
sorte de champion de l'environnement à
sincère ou pas je crois michel quand il
dit que monsieur couillard et c'est
nécessaire sauf que c'est assez facile
cette position en ce moment parce que
l'exploitation pétrolière d'anticosti
même s'il était prouvé qu'il ya des
réserves suffisantes intéressante c'est
pas demain la veille
pour plusieurs raisons prix du baril de
pétrole est à la baisse la production
est abondante trop abondante avec l'iran
qui arrivent sur le marché les
américains qui sont quasi autosuffisant
il n'y a pas personne qui voudrait
s'engager dans ce projet là de toute
façon dans l'immédiat michel pour le
parti québécois qui défend contrat
est-ce que c'est pas aussi une question
un peu d' équilibre parce que c'est pas
tout le monde qui est d'accord dans le
parti non au contraire je pense que ça
cause vraiment un malaise un autre
supposé au sein du pq on l'avait vu du
real à la course au leadership
souvenez-vous le seul qui était vraiment
catégorique
or appuyé à vouloir exploiter le pétrole
c'est un monsieur péladeau qui y
voyaient un atout de taille pour le pour
le mouvement souverainiste pour mais les
autres je me souviens d'alexandre
cloutier monique martin ouellette pierre
séré bon dans le cadre d'un ville c'est
moins clair mais il y avait une grande
partie du parti québécois qui
actuellement tourné la page sur le
pétrole alors monsieur couillard
c'est certainement un effet secondaire
rue de son point de vue de semer un peu
la devise biya au sein du pq ou
peut-être c'est l'effet principal aussi
recherchées comme j'ai dit je pense
vraiment c'est plus un jeu politique
certainement
c'est sûr que les retombées économiques
d'anticosti ça n'arriverait pas ici le
lendemain si jamais c'est certainement
une autre façon d'énerver monsieur
péladeau est de diviser les rangs de son
opposition
et qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de ce que
dit l'opposition opposition 10 un double
discours alors sur rona ont dit c'est
l'état de droit on peut pas on peut pas
intervenir dans cette vente là alors que
pour on serait prêt à vichy ray un
contrat à anticosti daniel je reçois
qu'il ya la comparaison aux tiennent de
rona c'est une institution bien établie
au québec qu'on a choisi de ne pas
sauver pour les réseaux qui sont celles
de monsieur couillard il les a largement
expliqué alors que l'exploration
pétrolière à anticosti ça n'existe pas
encore c'est un projet sur papier et si
on en juge que le prochain le projet
n'est pas rentable et qu'il est
dangereux pour l'environnement
à quoi bon aller de l'avant alors c'est
pas c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
ah oui c'est l'entreprise privée will a
signé un contrat avec avec une firme
d'exploration
sauf que si le contrat n'est pas bon
mais pourquoi ne pas le résilier ce qui
est ce qu'il va être intéressant de voir
si ce monsieur
cuias va avoir la même attitude en ce
qui concerne de près le projet énergie
est doublé entre la l'aja on va pouvoir
vérifier là comment dire la profondeur
de son sang social environnement il fait
soit de deux choses l'une soit il
préfère le terrain pour dire on est
responsable alors on peut confier
énergie est au gouvernement québécois on
va être responsable s'assurer que
l'environnement va être protégé où il
prépare le terrain pour dire ben non non
merci on s'éloigne du pétrole et on sait
pas encore c'est de toute façon la
décision finale sur l'énergie à seyssel
d'ottawa s'est pas celle de québec
ouais justement ottawa une des grosses
annonces qu'on attendait c'était le
retrait des f 18 canadiens à la
coalition internationale s'est fait donc
le 22 février
nos avions ne seront plus là sauf qu'en
contrepartie il y aura plus de
militaires sur le terrain le canada au
fond soit plus engagé
alors ta chose que les canadiens ont
voté pour ça est ce que est ce que c'est
ça qu'on leur a promis pas exactement je
pense que les canadiens qui évoque qui
ont voté pour le parti libéral en grande
partie les néo démocrates qui ont été
convertis au parti de monsieur trudeau
pour éliminer monsieur europe ont
vraiment voulu la faire qu'il n'y avait
pas d'avion de chasse qu'on serait
dégâts d engager ce serait plus gardiens
de la paix aide humanitaire
maintenant on va avoir trois triplés
essentiellement notre engagement potes
de combat mais des dead au combat teurs
l'entraîneur de russie un petit
dangereux absolument c'est plus risqué
et aussi ça veut dire qu'on va être là
dans le temps de plus long terme on sait
pas été la fin de cette mission bon on
ne sait pas comment ça va se dérouler
dans les prochaines années est ce qu'on
va encore augmenter ses nombre de
personnels ont fait pas michel oui moi
je suis assez d'accord avec avec l'achat
il ya c'est habile politiquement
monsieur trudeau tient sa promesse sans
trop mécontenter les alliés mais y'a de
la fausse représentation là dedans il
est clair que dans l'esprit des
électeurs
c'était un retrait plus ou moins
important de l'intervention militaire
canadienne
là-bas et la com du tasha il y en a plus
dans les faits les dangers pour les
troupes là-bas vont être là oui mais
c'est pas de la formation à l'école la
sentence et de la formation sur le
terrain
sur la ligne de front bien souvent les
militaires qui vont aller là vont être
beaucoup plus exposés en fait que ceux
qui conduisent les avions qui pilote les
avions actuellement
alors c'est habile mais il y un peu
d'hypocrisie la date
ouais mais depuis depuis les élections
depuis la promesse de justin trudeau de
rapatrier les chasseurs bombardiers
il ya eu paris il ya eu jakarta you
ouagadougou a changé considérablement d'
approche n'est peut-être plus
nécessairement la main parce que est ce
que le gouvernement canadien aurait pu
faire tout ce que monsieur trudeau a
annoncé le dit maintenir quand même des
avions de chasse probablement ça aurait
été beaucoup ce que le canada fait en ce
moment c'est exactement ce que fait
l'allemagne
et rien de plus rien de mois il faut
regarder aussi le tableau d'ensemble
mais dans le tableau d'ensemble
le canada accueille plus de réfugiés au
pro rata sa population que les
américains que bien d'autres pays donc
on peut débattre des mérites du clan de
monsieur trudeau à des avions de chasse
à vous permet de feu de l'action de
tirer directement sur l'ennemi plutôt
que de jouer derrière
à sauf que ils ont fait ils ont fait un
choix et le canada se retrouvent dans
une position qui est très semblable à
plusieurs de ses alliés d'ailleurs les
américains faisant que barack obama aime
beaucoup justin trudeau beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mais trois fois je
pense depuis le dire aussi que c'est
bien beau génial très content oui comme
assise c'est tout si sa tâche allait
dire écoute c'est pas vrai qu'on n'est
pas impliqué dans ces bombardements à
venir parce que effectivement on va
continuer de choisir les cibles qui vont
être bombardés par les autres notamment
londres qui va augmenter
le nombre d'avions qui vont contribuer
maintenant des avions maintenant plus
qu'un deuil se retire c'est un peu
ironique et de plus on vend toujours des
30 forme unitaire en arabie saoudite
selon le gouvernant a appuyé sa toujours
est très intéressant à l'adie saoudite
doit maintenant donner des troupes qui
vont qui vont être dans le combat avec
les forces de la coalition dans la
région il américains sont très contents
de ça alors pourvu que nos avions sont
pas là bon non militaires nos transports
vont être là alors peut-être c'est une
bonne chose pourrait en tout cas 10 voix
ensoleillée ça a l'air de bien aller
parce qu'avant il me conduit au canada y
compris au québec selon un sondage
publié dans votre journal michel donc on
a beaucoup parlé des libéraux la semaine
dernière par long des 100 jours de
l'opposition parce quand même pour le
npd
c'est pas très rose d'abord il est 100
jours d'un gouvernement qui a été élu
avec une majorité comme celle de
monsieur tour-du-pin espèce de daurade
marie la faim dans fin de campagne
c'est aussi le lendemain pour
l'opposition dans le cas de monsieur
moquer écoutez c'est une énorme défaite
pour le npd et au début de la campagne
ces gens là se voyait au pouvoir et le
résultat tout ça c'est qu'ils sont
passés de 103 compter à 44 à la il ya ça
fait mal maintenant monsieur on voit
monsieur marqué vu rester la prochaine
fois c'est sa faute faute avouée est à
moitié pardonnée le dit le proverbe
mais il ya quand même beaucoup à se
faire pardonner parce que non seulement
il ya eu la défaite a été sévère mais
pour arriver à la victoire monsieur marc
a ramené son parti à renier une partie
de son âme social démocrate
j'imagine que ion il sait jamais on doit
être très très indulgent envers leur
chef faut changer de chef à chaque
élection qui perdent et ils y perdent
tout mais là en plus de sorts l'aurait
on les a forcés à se renier en bonne
partie alors j'imagine qui a déjà je ne
vous dis pas que monsieur monde qu'elle
va être renversé au congrès d'avril mais
sur certains qui a déjà qu'ils vont
avoir de la difficulté à lui pardonner
est ce qui te s'en remettre bagnell ce
qui peut s'en remettre
en politique tout est possible il n'y a
pas d'eau tattu aujourd'hui elle a été
reçue par tirer des câbles des kids
il faut absolument 70%
au congrès de qui aurait lieu dans
l'ouest au printemps prochain bernard
landry michel si je me souviens bien
avait quitté avec quoi 81 bon sens c'est
possible mais c'est à moi que ce stade
la barre des 80% et joe clark à 66% donc
écouter la barre est à 70%
c'est pas très élevé il me semble sauf
que y'en a marre tient en ce moment de
ce malaise une torpeur le parti
enchantement toi monsieur lecard a perdu
son mordant
on sent quelque chose qui flottent
personne n'en veut vraiment houndété
vraiment monsieur molière mais personne
ne prend vraiment sa défense est
vraiment en adoration devant monsieur
molière est un espèce de flottement il
n'y a pas de candidats par an pour le
remplacer mais il faut connaître le
nouveau parti démocratique mais celle là
dit il ya des valeurs fondamentales qui
sont très importantes
si on a l'impression qu'elles sont et et
renier ou que monsieur molière peut pas
défendre adéquatement y gagnera pas au
congrès d'avril
tasha parlons des conservateurs parce
que pour eux aussi quand même ça a été
une défaite aussi on fait un peu sont
venus sur la campagne ont dit qu'ils
avaient peut-être sous-estimé le désir
de changement des canadiens changement 1
c'est radical et on découvre en même
temps une chef intérimaire qui s'en sort
assez bien rona ambrose on l'avait pas
très bien beaucoup connu comme ministre
mais là elle s'en sort assez bien oui
tout le monde sort de l'ombre
semble-t-il dans ce gouvernement ou dans
l'opposition qui étaient le lot en
nommant sur absolument et manu mambo
c'est une exemple classique je pense
qu'on l'a on l'a vraiment pas connu
pendant les années qu'elle était
ministre d'ailleurs le gouvernement de
monsieur et elle se débrouille très bien
les troupes conservateurs sont très
contente de sa présentation et la façon
qu'elle qu'elle pose des questions en
chambre et qu'elle se présente et de
partis aussi va voir un congrès on sait
ça en mai à vancouver et c'est fort
possible
moi je pense probable que les candidats
à la chefferie vont se déclarer à ce
moment là où avant ce moment là parce
que ça leur donnerait assez de temps
pour pour travailler les trous depuis
dix ans sur le terrain avant leur
principe présenter parce qu'elle était
l'un des noms et il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se disent mais pourquoi peut-être
changer les règles on va voir mais
écoute je ne sais pas si elle
elle désire le poste à long terme et
elle serait une excellente candidate ya
pas de questions un mot daniel jeu tout
à fait d'accord je suis très
impressionné par sept ministres qu'on ne
voyait jamais la même et ministre de
l'environnement rappelez-vous et jamais
on entendait parler d'elle elle se
débrouille fort bien le seul reproche
que je lui ferai ce que elle l'a parfois
l'impression donne parfois l'impression
de ne défendre que l'alberta et des
projets pétroliers à doit se rappeler
qu'au québec les conservateurs ont
doublé leur nombre de sièges qui a
beaucoup de conservateurs qui sont pas
d'accord une eau plus avec le projet
énergie est un mot de la femme chez les
conservateurs sont en meilleur état que
les néo-démocrates là ils ont perdu mais
leurs bases et en contre est très solide
alors je pense que disons il parle de
beaucoup moins loin pour la prochaine
élection et guy la droite demeure uni
enfin il y en a qu'un seul parti alors
que ça va être la même chose la
prochaine fois si le cnp des réussi à
retomber sur ses pieds le vote
progresser centre guillemets va être
encore une fois de les aiguiser en tout
cas on n'a pas revu vraiment monsieur
harper depuis la défaite
une photo avec la leur compte tant mieux
merci beaucoup à vous trois à la semaine
prochaine